everybody knows these hits everybody was
they topped the charts for weeks the
world over but that was that and the
musicians never managed to land a second
hit the phenomenon of the one-hit
wonders caught the imagination of
Carolyn Lauren an illustrator based in
Hamburg yeah I did préfon I'm from said
they just capture the spirit of their
time they perfectly fit the musical
fashion of the moment the songs were
well produced and the performances were
good and authentic Libert decided to put
together a book on a subject with texts
by journalist Marcus Lucas they picked
out some of the best stories of the
musical flash in the pan the selection
process was far from easy young via page
veton the sprockets the book could
easily have been twice as long but the
publisher said 80 pages is about right
we only chose artists who had one
international hit that was one of the
criteria das fazal desk italian leather
creates illustrations for magazines and
newspapers for the book she drew 60
years of one-hit wonders one of the
earliest is from 1958 Domenico Madhu
know with no blue del punto de blue also
known as Volare
Oh
it sold 20 million copies liberty is
particularly fond of vintage one-offs
like Louie Louie by the Kingsmen the 50s
and 60s boasted lots of one-hit wonders
y damas de novo in the rock and roll era
loads of musicians suddenly emerged and
had songs released because rock and roll
was really hot too tall and is often
this [ __ ] so many him take time with a
single song but never followed it up
there was an incredible number of
artists making music at the time the
book also tells the stories behind the
songs live is life by the Austrian band
opus is a love song address to their
vans it was recorded at a concert in
1984
ladies and gentlemen this is Mambo
number 5 a little bit of money Mambo
number 5 by Lou Bega dates from 1999
it's an old tune with a new libretto in
rap form and it sees him listing his
former girlfriend it was number one in
22 countries but it remained beggars
only hit whomented one-hit wonder if the
sounds the single hit was a curse for
others are blessing the oasis for it
wasn't cursed for those who got stuck in
a certain musical niche but wanted to
move on and do other things while
everybody focused on their one head
songs so he didn't Zig mrs. food it was
a blessing for those who wanted a nice
income in diesel divinity and couldn't
destroyed it these two elderly gents are
probably still receiving a tidy sum in
royalties for Macarena labret set out to
convey the mood the feel of a song that
meant listening to each closely at least
to start with you have the Thunder
spooky I didn't listen to them all the
time while I was drawing I watched the
videos once as I was doing some sketches
but anymore might have proved
destructive if you listen to them over
and over mavi does Allah up wit her
antidote was to listen to classical
music because it has to be said some
one-hit wonders could stick with you
forever
da da da
you